in less than 48 hours cobit 19
restrictions will loosen up in clark
county
yeah capacity limits will increase now
to 80 percent but do businesses have
enough staff to keep up with the demand
eight news now reporter victoria saha
takes a closer look
even though many businesses have not
been able to bring their full staff back
they say they are looking forward to
more patrons being allowed back in
saturday will be a game changer but
there's one issue in the recovery
process staffing
at tacos and beer co-owner john simmons
says pre-pandemic he had about 50
employees
now it's around 35. we have to pull them
back in
and takes a little time i mean i think a
lot of people have actually even moved
out of vegas because vegas was hit so
hard by this
but he's grateful for the employees he
does have
and make sure they know they're
appreciated
we raise people's pay because it's it's
just been harder on them
but they're getting they're getting over
time and they're making more money
and that's a good thing to fill the
remainder of the staffing gap simmons is
continuously hiring at parkway tavern a
big turnout is expected saturday
for a block party those things that
we've been waiting to do for so long
haven't been able to they're all coming
back all in one day
they haven't had many issues when it
came to staffing we also have locations
on the las vegas strip so we were able
to
move people around and keep them
employed keep them
working which was our ultimate goal
throughout everything business owners
say the number one goal is to make sure
everyone has a good time and stay safe
victoria saha 8 news now